is do you guys believe that soul mates
are real yes or no
[Music]
sorry
no he can go first the way you said the
way he said it's like you you were ready
well no i do i know
well okay because i know my beliefs and
like i definitely think soul mates are
real but i don't think you have just one
soul i think that there's twin flames
you have soul mates but i don't think i
think in life you evolve so much that
you have multiple soul mates and it
depends on that period of time in your
life and where you're at and soul
connections are real like i think like
i've had soul mates that are friends i
know that for sure are we still met
[ __ ] we're soulmates
you you know like soul connections are
real but that doesn't mean that it's
just one person
or just one sex or one gender that's my
take
interesting interesting interesting
well
i do agree with her in the sense that i
don't think you have one just like i
don't think that
you fall in love just with just one
person over your lifetime you'll fall in
love with someone multiple people
you have multiple soul mates
when in terms of soul mates i believe
like sometimes it's more sexual
it could be
intellectual like your soulmate can be
connected between like various factors
and all
so
i do believe in soul mates different
factors for that though
hey listen i agree with both parties
um
as a man
i'm i'm coming from most people are
going to go back to their belief beliefs
in terms of how they were brought up
um me being a christian man
i definitely believe in soul mates and
that you have multiple
partners at different points in your
life
and when things fail god will arrive
something new that being said wait we
have a question so
so you're christian
how do you believe in multiple soul
mates
at different points in your how
difficult your life so okay so as you
grow as a human being you can meet
somebody that you're not ready for and
god put that person in your life
and he put the person in your life to
teach you a lesson for what's to come
and that person could be at 18 to 20
years old
from 22 to 25 that person could be from
30 to 33 and when you get married or
whatever time is
outside give you a little
chronicological timeline from
35
to the rest of your life until you die
so
that being said um it's just at
different points in your life
like the people that spoke before me
said and
i just believe that
uh when the time is right
uh obviously you
learn from your past relationships
you're supposed to look yourself in the
mirror and say where did i go wrong
what can i do better and what can i do
to you know put myself in a position to
succeed in terms of you know hopefully
being married for wrestlemania
pass away
see it's interesting because i don't
believe in soul mates at all okay
okay but can i ask okay yeah i can
listen to your podcast like you have
told me before that you're very
religious so how does that relate to
your religious beliefs that you don't
believe in like soulmates well i think
religion
it comes down to choices so if i started
let's say i started and only fans
tomorrow would that change the type of
husband i get no no i think it does i
think your choices affect like the type
of person that's the right i feel like
the right person for you could look past
that [ __ ] and
sorry stuff
the right man it may and when i say the
right man i'm not saying that it's like
a man like a man could be one way with
you and a different way with another
girl that's right for them so the right
man for you would be able to look past
that and that's all i'll say so if i
started porn tomorrow i can't say that
on youtube corn
tomorrow
you think the right man should just look
look past that if he's your the right
person for you yes 100 he should be no i
i really think it's your choice but what
about in life if you start doing corn
yeah but what if that is like
you have lived a life and this is a way
for you to make money and provide for
yourself or
vice versa you never know someone's
story right you know what i'm saying and
there are people that just
do it you know everyone's different but
like
you know if
if that's what you did to provide or
just to survive or you went through
certain things in your life that have
made you be hyper sexual
and what not well i mean
the thing is i know i've lived like i
you know i had a very sheltered like
childhood so i'm in a situation where
like
you know i'm not gonna judge someone for
what they've had to do when i like
haven't had to like struggle like that
you know but
at the same time like it's gonna be your
future husband starts off as a complete
stranger so how is he supposed to not
judge you when he doesn't know you well
i think that also depends on like
for example if you're somebody who
would never
resort to that
you're probably going to look for a
partner who wouldn't be with someone who
would respond to that right but that's
why i i think it comes back to like the
choices you make or the as that's the
type of partner you end up with yeah
because i think like you want someone
with the same values as you
so but does doing like
sex work per se
there are values and morals like
personally that's not something i would
do right
personally
but when i look at other people that
do that kind of stuff i don't say well
what are your morals and what are your
values i've more more so think of
what brought you to this point in your
life to where you felt that you had to
well there's a difference like there's
some people who just do it because they
don't give a sh
sorry yeah but you know there's also
people that do it a lot of girls do it
because they feel like they don't have
another option
okay i'll ask you guys would you guys
date a girl would you marry a girl
mother of your children
who has done corn
i want you to go first come on please
listen
i agree with um
both of what you're saying to be honest
but i follow more so
what pearl's saying we all have choices
like you can be from
a poor background and still be
successful you could choose
a life that's
makes you a bad quote-unquote bad
citizen
or you can
choose bad citizens that's a strong word
very bad
listen you could be a criminal you could
you could but what is okay criminal and
sex work is super
about it you don't have to be a sex
worker you there's so many things but
but exactly what about sex work think
about it your body if you think about it
your body we're talking about we're
talking about
soul ties right now
giving yourself to multiple people
here and there you don't think you're
getting soul ties from that but but in
what way are you talking about
physically or just over like uh
it's different with physically and then
emotionally as well you can give
yourself to someone
physically but you never gave them to
emotion it's quite different in my
opinion okay also let's talk about the
fact that this whole
world of of only fans and whatnot was
the consumers are men
it's not women it's men and women have
been over sexualized throughout their
life and
have been you know we sexualize
ourselves uh i'm sorry
that's not true because no it's not no
it's not because we grow up in a society
that that tells you
like men will want you if you are a
certain type of way right so like
okay like sex work women